she pointed the gun at the person and
told her she was going to bust her what
I did not say that all right he's
starting to
move yeah he's
running he just fell
down come on mother okay think I can't
do it I know black a black belt J
Florida man wild stories involving
residents of the Sunshine State have
been making headlines for years and for
good reason we're breaking down the top
10 Florida man or woman arrests caught
on camera welcome to after hours
presented by law and crime I'm Sam
Goldberg first we're in South Beach
Miami where a man allegedly tried to
steal a jet ski then jumped into the
ocean and took off his swim trunks it's
Sunday April 2nd 2023 police responded
to a report that a man had tried to take
a jet ski available for rent without
permission try to do was got one of the
keys from the he tried to P the out so
he can
so the so you guys never you guys never
gent everything record he actually gra
the yes he tried to grab the paper from
the
key he grabbed the paddles TR to hit us
broke one the business manager tells
police the man broke a paddle and triy
to hit him in the head with it before
going into the water police on Shore
wait for Marine Patrol to arrive but the
water is to shallow for the boats to get
too close that's when the suspect
decides to strip down in full view of
everyone on the beach including
[Music]
children hey we we'll get this exposure
second the man can be heard yelling and
even singing in multiple languages the
officers tried to get him to come out of
the ocean but it's not
working okay come
on for eventually several fellow
beachgoers took matters into their own
hands they surrounded the suspect in the
water and eventually dragged him to the
sand
[Applause]
the officers cover him up with a towel
and drag him from the water up onto the
Beach then put him onto the back of a
golf cart just swim you guys hting me
shame on you nobody's hitting they took
him to be looked over by First
Responders putting him onto a stretcher
and into an ambulance the suspect tells
officers his name is Neil but is
eventually identified as yakiv Levi he
was arrested and charged with aggravated
battery on a law enforcement officer
resisting an officer with violence lewd
Behavior aggravated battery proving a
false name after arrest and Grand Theft
next we're in Tampa Florida it's just
after 700 p.m. on Christmas Eve 2023
according to police 34-year-old elezar
Armando reos Rios crashed his car but
when an officer arrived to try to help
him Rios took off running eventually
climbing a fence into a construction
site the Hillsboro County Sheriff's
Office used its helicopter to track him
all right we do have a subject just
north of a tree he's on the south east
corner looks like it's a he's in a
covert he's you won't be able to see him
from where you're at because it's a cul
I just realized but you are right across
from Rios doesn't seem too concerned
about what's going on as he lays
underneath the tree yeah just so you all
know he's just sort of casually laying
there with his arms behind his head he
even starts to make dirt angels with his
arms Rios then decides to leave his
hiding place and try to make a run for
it but that doesn't go exactly to plan
all right he's starting to
move yeah he's
running he just fell down he's
running towards the West the Sheriff's
Office sent in an officer with his
canine who was able to take Rios into
custody get on the ground shut up get on
the ground or you're going to get bit
get on the ground or you're going to get
bit hey this is your final warning get
on the ground or you're going B Ros was
charged with leaving the scene of an an
incident driving with a canceled
suspended or revoked license trespassing
on a construction site and resisting an
officer without
violence Now we move to Coco Florida and
this time it's a Florida woman who's in
trouble with the law police responded to
a McDonald's fast food restaurant on
March 16th 2023 around 11:00 p.m. for a
report of a woman threatening employees
with a gun they found quave young inside
her SUV at the drive-through window put
that gun away put it down
the officers get young out of the car
and put her in
handcuffs what is the problem apparently
they saw your gun and they thought it's
in the it's in the car I have it in my
car that's where I have it okay I'm just
telling you it's no big deal she got mad
because she she got mad because I asked
for my order that was the problem I
didn't do nothing all I said was I'm
still waiting on my number one order
because I asked for now I'm trying to go
home she got mad it was aome crazy I'm
like what are you talking about so I'm
I'm wait I'm still here here waiting
okay I got a gun from and I'm still
waiting we don't know all that I don't
care that's the crazy part she can C she
can say what she want to say that's
weird I'm still here waiting on my damn
order young is insistent that this is
all some sort of misunderstanding what
is I'm being sto for what is the problem
I just told you no you did not sir no
you didn't saw your gun okay that you
were threatening her I did not threaten
her with nothing sir at all I did not
threaten her with nothing that's what
we're here no I've been sitting in the
car why would I threaten someone I'm
still sitting in my car waiting on my D
order that doesn't make any sense I
don't know she don't she's not making
any s that's what we're here to figure
out according to the employees young
ordered a meal that wasn't on the menu
and became irate when they told her she
needed to order something else she
reportedly drove up to the first window
and again demanded the off menu meal she
pointed at the person and told her she
was going to bust her what I did not say
that she's a damn liar you going to
watch the video no she's not going to
sit here and me like that no she's not
going to do that and I'm going to call
my mom right now cuz she that's weird as
hell ex get my um no I'm going to get my
I'm going to get my own phone thank you
so she's a he's a liar she's a liar an
officer goes inside to talk to the
McDonald's employees and check out store
security video and it's not good news
for young when he comes back out you
want to put her in the car yeah okay for
what his car you're under arrest for
what what what what did I
do what did I do can you turn assault
assault of
what she assault uh yeah assault like
how is that assault I didn't oh you you
telling somebody that you're going to
hurt them you got a gun next to you I
didn't tell her I was going to hurt her
oh that's what her D saying that's the
call that we got young was taken to jail
where she continued to repeat that she
hadn't done anything wrong while she was
being booked I didn't even do nothing
all I said was all she didn't get my
order right then I have already I mean
that it was in my car anyways I a say
that I was going to shoot her or even
point it towards her well that in and of
itself is a second Dee misor to have it
open in your
vehicle I didn't assult
her I just get a order it's okay know
you can't do nothing about it and I
can't
even I young was then charged with
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
open carrying of a firearm and driving
with a suspended license she's expected
back in court for a status hearing at
the end of
January so I think it's pretty clear
from watching after hours as I know
everyone does every single week the
world isn't always the safest place it's
important to realize if you're ever
seriously hurt your injury could
actually be worth millions that's where
Morgan and Morgan a proud sponsor of
after hour hours comes in Morgan and
Morgan doesn't just settle for lowball
offers in the past couple months they've
seen verdicts of 12 million in Florida
26 million in Philadelphia and 6.8
million in New York and here's the
kicker the fee is absolutely free unless
you win you can start your claim with
America's largest injury law firm in
just a single click on your phone
they've completely modernized the injury
law process so you can submit a claim
and communicate with your legal Team all
from your phone you don't even have to
leave your couch to do so so to start
your claim now with Morgan and Morgan go
to ww. forthepeople.com back/ after
hours or click the link in the
description and in the pinned
comments next we head to Davenport
Florida it's Monday November 13th 2023
deputies responded to a neighborhood
where two suspects a man and a woman
were apparently breaking into cars
surveillance video captures what
happened when police showed up to the
scene the white sedan speeding past the
deput ities is the suspect car they're
driving around trying to find an exit
but the subdivision only has one when
the suspects turned around they ended up
crashing into a car that was fortunately
unoccupied it's a good thing the deputy
decided to move his Cruiser because the
white car ends up Landing where it was
parked just moments later 31-year-old
Rebecca kab was taken to a hospital with
a fractured leg from the crash
37-year-old Timothy hoi was booked for a
burglary of an unoccupied veh vehicle
Petty Larsen fleeing police possession
of meth and resisting arrest he'll be
back in court at the end of February and
get this on his neck is the tattoo quote
all gas no breaks both kib and hoi have
a long criminal history with dozens of
felonies and misdemeanors between them
next we're in Flagler County where
officials say A man stole an expensive
electric scooter from a Target store
then started to assemble it right
outside it's a April 3rd 2023 a witness
says a man took a Razer brand es scooter
valued at more than $500 out of the
store without paying for it what's going
on man
up p stand up huh stand up I'm going to
detain you for a second the man who was
later identified as Patrick Vander
Maiden Miller was cooperative with the
deputy to appoint you buy this
scooter you don't want to answer that
question the deputy arrested Vander
Maiden Miller and found drug
paraphernalia in his pocket he was
charged with Petty larsy and possession
of drug paraphernalia and held on a
$2,000
Bond now we're back in P County where
another man was arrested for theft and
it's what he's accused of stealing that
really made the headlines 26-year-old
Toby Foster turned himself into the
sheriff's office after apparently being
caught on video taking ingredients for a
cocktail from an apartment deputies say
on November 23rd 2023 around 5:30 in the
morning Foster broke into an apartment
and stole vodka and orange juice the
common ingredients for a screwdriver
Foster was caught on surveillance camera
he was charged with burglary of a
dwelling and Petty
Larsen now we're in Port Orange just
south of Daytona Beach it's Tuesday May
9th 2023 at 12:30 in the afternoon
police responded to a smoke shop on a
report of a man being disrupted and
threatening workers um I don't know if
he is still sitting out there at the
moment um he might be the guy at
Alberto's but I called about him causing
a disturbance and he's come in here
quite a few times already and has
bothered me and customers he makes me
very uncomfortable he said a lot of
vulgar things to me and he likes to grab
things and try and come by in the
account so kind of want him to trespass
the officer finds William busy in the
same shopping center busy tells the
officer he has a question question I was
arrested about 8 months ago okay back up
for me a little bit pleas I was arrested
8 months ago and I spent 18 months in
prison which was not fun I'm so glad to
be out but anyways I'm
suing the malucha county sheriff I'm
suing this is all with my lawyer is
currently underway what's your question
just get to that if I sue the port orang
the police department and they give me
$250,000 that's taxfree right I have no
idea okay I'll have to to my account
about that okay the officer then tries
to get things back on track you are now
trespassed from the store which means
you cannot go in there anymore do you
understand that all right then she'll
have to set my stuff outside there what
stuff I have $2,000 worth of merchandise
that she's holding bus's demeanor
suddenly changes and he becomes
incredibly combative no she said that
she run a bu stuff up for you never
bought go ask her you mother okay come
over here and
I'll you come on mother okay think I
can't do it I know black Bel and Cate a
black belt and Cheo you understand your
trespass store correct I'll take your
gun and Walkie Talkie okay and I'll
drive off of your patrol car okay you
understand your trespass from the store
correct yes I understand you mother okay
now get the out of my face I'm 12T away
from you not in your face at
all okay busy just threw a piece of
lunch meet at the officer and the cop at
this point has had enough wait a
minute okay your you're under arrest put
your hand now put your other hand behind
your back right now right now put your
other hand behind your
back Jesus Christ put your hand behind
your backat right now busy tells the
officer that his arrest will only lead
to more legal action this is another
lawsuit I'm suing you for a million 10
million whatever
wait till my lawyer gets a hold of this
right now you're under arrest for
battery on law enforcement officer for
throwing something at me oh the launch
yeah well don't do it why would you
throw some at me cuz you piss me off
that's well there you go busy continues
to prove that he's a man who doesn't
quite know when to quit you're lucky I
didn't have my pocket knife with me i'
stab your you be dead right now busy was
booked for battery on a police officer
in October busy was sentenced to 200
days in jail
next we're back in Flagler County where
a man allegedly punched his neighbor in
the face then jumped into a canal to try
to get away from police what are you
doing dude what are you doing this for
it's Sunday November 19th 2023 just
before 5 p.m. Flagler County deputies
say Philip McGraw walked into his
neighbor's garage and then hit him both
men ended up in the street and McGraw
stepdad pulled up in a truck mcra hopped
in and the men took off deputies tried
to do a traffic stop but the stepfather
kept driving eventually ending up back
where it all started that's when Deputy
say McGraw jumped into the water and
swam through multiple canals to try to
avoid
capture you have any weapons on
you roll up M gr ended up going to jail
soaking wet deputies charged him with
unarmed burglary of an occupied dwelling
simple battery petty theft and resisting
an officer without violence MRA entered
to no contest plea and was ordered to
pay almost $300 in fines and go to jail
for 30 days now we go to P County where
a man delivering for door Dash allegedly
wanted more for his Services than just a
tip on the app identified by the
sheriff's office as Saleem dropping off
a customer's Taco Bell order in May of
2023 he looks directly at the camera
several times before taking a photo of
the food for proof of delivery but then
he decides to take an Amazon package
from the front studio scop and puts it
under his shirt the customer then
reported the theft to the Sheriff's
Office and they subpoena door Dash to
identify the driver Saleem was arrested
and charged with burglary and petty
theft for taking the package which had
an oil filter inside worth only about
$8 our last stop on this Florida man
journey is in Citrus County where the
Sheriff's Office featured a Florida
woman on its warrant of the week social
media Post in November 2023 the
Sheriff's Office posted a photo of Stacy
Usher who apparently tried to hide from
deputies inside of a couch deputies had
been searching for her after they say
she violated her probation by selling
fentanyl Usher is a convicted felon in
multiple Florida counties with a history
of drug fraud grand theft and using
bogus checks the Florida man phenomenon
is so well known organizers have put
together the quote Florida Man games set
to take place in St Augustine in
February one of the events is the quote
evading arrest obstacle course where
participants will run from actual
officers the website also boasts a mud
wrestling event mullet contest and
boxing match showdown between police and
firefighters thanks for watching for Law
and Crime After Hours I'm Sam
Goldberg